now president joe biden delivered
remarks at a build back better event
earlier today now the speech was riddled
with lies that'll go unchecked by the
media but are worth documenting here as
the economy slides back to the 1970s
line number one
biden says the inflation report is
good news for america
today i'm pleased to share more good
news with the american people
the latest report on consumer price
shows
prices show
that we've expanded some easy now excuse
me the expected easing we thought was
going to come has increased that we are
we've seen a good monthly report
okay well reality inflation isn't just
up 5.4 percent annually the specific
sectors hurt americans
well since last year gas prices are up
41.8 percent used cars up 41.7 percent
food prices
up five point four percent and
electricity up four percent
further average hourly wages
they're not tracking with these price
increases they're only up four percent
from a year ago meaning the 5.4 percent
inflation increase completely wipes out
any wage gain
line number two
he's not standing in the way of oil
price decreases
i want to make sure
that nothing stands in the way of oil
price declines leading to lower prices
for consumers we also made clear to opec
that the production cuts made during the
pandemic should be reversed as the
global economic as the global economy
recovers in order to lower prices for
consumers
reality well biden stood in the way of
oil price decreases starting on day one
of his presidency when he killed the
keystone pipeline all the regulations
they're putting on drilling suspending
drilling leases on federal lands and now
he's been forced to plead with opec how
embarrassing
please boost oil production since gas
prices are starting to hurt me
politically
lie number three
biden says he
bought an economy brought by an economy
back from
well basically it was dead
we brought this economy back from a cold
start
and there is going to be uh there are
going to be some ups and downs need to
make this economy work better for
working families in the long run
these challenges are with us long before
the pandemic and before i took office
okay here's the reality unemployment
peaked at 14.8 percent in april of 2020.
economists thought it was going to stay
high for a long time but what happened
trump and the red states reopened
reopened the economy causing
unemployment to plunge down to 6.3
percent in january when trump left
office
but under biden unemployment has only
fallen .9 points
and before the pandemic median household
income remember it went up five thousand
dollars during trump's presidency and
unemployment was at historic lows
joe you may be fooling the rest of the
press
but not the angle